you have a 16 month old right yeah I do
yeah that I mean okay and you just
started on a new show which we're gonna
talk about but yeah I think yeah I felt
like I went to work too early with my
first one and it was exhausting it was
exhausting yeah I was 35 months after I
started five months after but just
acting is exhaust it's not like I don't
know it just takes all of your mental
capacity kind of I cried to my
mother-in-law week two because she came
to help me and I was just I don't know
how I'm gonna just cried and I just
cried I was like I can't do this home
like I just I just stay at home but now
recently like tent-like when he turned
10 months I got held finally because I
have a weird job you know I'm like home
all the time but I also have to read and
do other things during the day so I
can't let your gone all the door I'm
gone yeah so I but now I got my own wife
I realize like having an and he's like
having a wife oh my gosh it's the best
thing on the planet Earth like she's
cooking an amazing pesto dish room this
kid eats better than I have ever eaten
in my life oh my god she's a chef too oh
yeah she does it all you can look how
much he really did I love that I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this